Spaceflight does a number on our bodies — we
lose muscle mass and density, fluids shift
in strange ways, there’s even evidence that
radiation exposure in space increases risk
of developing Alzheimer's disease.
And now new research has revealed that long-term
missions expand brain tissue with some scary
results.
I’m never going to get to go to Mars.
In all the research done on how spaceflight
affects the body, there’s been fairly little
done on the brain, specifically brain tissue
and the cerebrospinal fluid space.
But that’s not because astronauts don’t
show signs of some kind of brain changes when
they return from a stint on the International
Space Station.
Many exhibit symptoms of an ill-understood
condition called "visual impairment intracranial
pressure” syndrome (VIIP) — they report
poorer vision upon landing that can last for
years, and physicals show some of the cause
is swelling of the eye's optic disk as well
as increased pressure in the skull.
So, a team of set out to study these changes
before they happen.
They used MRIs to look at astronauts’ brains
before and after long and short duration missions
— 165 days on average for long and 13 days
on average short flights.
Physicians then read the scans looking for
displacement of brain tissue and narrowing
of cerebrospinal fluid spaces — that’s
the space where the spinal fluid roots in
the brain.
One point of interest was the central sulcus,
a cleft running through the middle of the
brain that divides the areas responsible for
motor control and sensory input.
They found the central sulcus narrowed in
almost all cases of long duration missions
but very few on short flights.
Also after long missions, scans showed an
upward shift of the brain tissue against the
top of the skull as well as a narrowing in
the space for the spinal fluid.
In the short term comparisons, only one astronaut
showed narrowing in the space for the spinal
fluid in the brain.
It’s not entirely surprising that something
like this happens.
Our bodies are adapted for the gravity field
on Earth, and when you take that away our
systems keep working with some odd effects.
But all this might sound worse than it is…This
is a classic case of “more research is needed.”
For the moment scientists aren’t sure what
this narrowing means, whether or not it actually
has an impact on the flow of spinal fluid
or puts more pressure on brain tissue.
It’s one of many studies NASA is conducting
about how space affects the brain, including
impacts on motor control and multi-tasking
abilities.
If we’re going to send astronauts to Mars,
we’re going to need to make sure they get
there with healthy brains.
For more science in your day, be sure to subscribe
to Seeker, and if you want to know what another
big space danger -- radiation -- does, Amy's
got the answer right here.
And speaking of heads in space, Apollo astronauts
saw flashes in their eyeballs!
They were cosmic rays. That's so cool.
Again, Thanks for watching.